we have an incredible bit of news the
White House called a trump rioter on
January 6th
uh oh
why would that be the case well let's
see if we can figure this out but this
is blowing the lid off of yet
another part of the Trump Riot
investigation there's a CNN article that
summarizes this quite well listen to
this on January 6th at 4 34 pm
cell phone registered to a capital right
a rioter who stormed the capital got a
phone call from a White House landline
okay CNN has obtained the records other
news outlets have looked at the records
this happened okay White House calls
calls a trump rioter on January 6. the
call lasts nine seconds hmm who placed
the call from the White House well we
don't know right now because the White
House has landlines and many people work
at the White House so we don't know
could have been anybody who works at the
White House okay
according to the records the call came
from a 202 number which is the publicly
available number for the White House
doesn't show a specific extension so we
don't know who's whose phone it came
from the call was placed in the late
afternoon right after Trump did the
video message saying to the rioters we
love you but go home
it's unclear CNN writes what if any
connection exists between the White
House and the rioter including whether
the call was made by mistake and whether
the call went to voicemail
mistake
that'd be quite a coincidental wrong
number quite a coincidental wrong number
um what else do we know about it well we
know who the call was made to
the cell phone belonged to a 26 year old
Trump supporter from Brooklyn New York
named Anton lennick
who traveled to DC the night before with
two friends according to multiple
sources familiar with the investigation
the three men attended the stop the
steel rally on the ellipse and then with
hundreds of others entered and illegally
demonstrated inside the capital
they were charged they pleaded guilty in
April and they were sentenced
um earlier this month
all three declined to comment to CNN
according to multiple sources Lennox
says he doesn't remember getting that
nine second call from the White House
and says he doesn't know anyone who
worked in the Trump White House
the phone call wasn't mentioned in
Lennox sentencing or in any court
documents and a spokesman for the U.S
attorney's Office in D.C has declined to
comment so what exactly does this mean
and there are a number of questions here
number one how do you not remember a
phone call from the White House did you
didn't get the call or you got it but
you don't remember what was said or they
left you a voicemail or what you have no
memory of it that's different than I
never received such a call
I have no memory of it that's really
weird
it's obviously very difficult to believe
that it's a random coincidence there's a
riot going on
Trump says to the rioters that he loves
them but it's time to go home
one of the rioters is at the Capitol
and the White House it's like a butt
dial someone just happens to
accidentally call the phone of the
rioter doesn't really make sense so it
obviously leads to speculation could it
be well someone at the white house uh
was in touch with this rioter met to
call the rioter on their cell phone but
realized they were using the White House
line and so they quickly hung up is that
a possibility again we're left to
speculate because the official
explanation so far don't make absolutely
any sense uh this particular writer
lunick was seen in the background of an
individual named baked Alaska's live
stream from Jeff merkley's office on
January 6th they'd broken into Jeff
merkley's office lanik you can see in
the background of a baked Alaska live
stream is it possible someone at the
White House was watching the Stream
sawlonic was like oh that's the guy
we've been in touch with or I know that
guy or something the other speculation
is lunick agreed to cooperate to some
degree for a lighter sentence is that
related to why there seems to be no
comment from anybody and not much of a
desire seemingly to get to the bottom of
who it is from the White House that
called Lennox only questions right now
but the fact that someone from the White
House called this guy
on the day of the riots raises all new
sets of questions about the connections
between the Trump White House and the
rioters not generally right of course
you can say well generally they were
like we'll make a speech and we'll say
let's walk down to Pennsylvania walk
down Pennsylvania Avenue and some of
these people are going to follow okay
fine we knew that this is about the
specific connection between an
individual at the White House and this
particular writer on that exact day
will we ever know what happened yeah I
think we actually will I think it's
likely that we will get to the bottom of
this multiple news agencies working on
it but it doesn't look good what do you
believe is the explanation for this
phone call let me know you can find me
on Twitter at dpacman
the David packman shows longest running
sponsor is blinkist the app that takes
thousands of non-fiction books boils
each of them down into an explainer you
can read or listen to in 15 minutes
blinkist also condenses episodes of
popular podcasts into 15-minute
explainers I've been using blinkist for
years to supplement the books I read I
love reading I I read all the time but
there's even more books I don't have
time to read and you can often find
those non-fiction books on blinkist and
consume the entire thing in 15 minutes
my favorite new feature on the app is
blinkist connect which lets you share
your blinkist premium account with
someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcasts between users I have a joint
blinkist premium account with my
girlfriend blinkist connect lets us sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist Sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to Robert Greene's the 48 Laws of Power
the new version Robert Greene super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a premium
subscription at blinkist.com
davidpackman the link is down below